My aunt, tell me
1 European country that does not belong to the European Union.
Japan, very good,
1 Great European country.
Except for another one that is slightly more European than Japan,
China,
that is European.
There it is,
capital of Ireland?
I have no idea.
It starts with le,
le
le pre
is in another language,
that warns him.
No idea.
Gentleman of the Czech Republic,
So Chicano was a Checkanese Republic?
Gentilius of Scotland?
I don't know either.
Scotland is not cooked.
You don't know any Scotsman,
Scottish,
Did I choose?
Scottish.
What is the flag of the European Union like?
Blue?
What else,
the stars?
How many many?
How many,
more or less?
10, 15,
10, 15?
I know.
Visualize the flag,
you don't visualize it,
yes,
if you visualize it you are not able to count them.
He can't imagine you have the flag in front of you under your nose,
In 2nd place in which country is the Vatican?
No idea.
1 track is 1 European country,
China,
perfect.
It is clear that people know a lot about Europe,
so there is no need to remind them
that June 9 is the elections
to elect the members of the European Parliament.
But just in case,
I leave it here